Hey everyone, I know things look a bit different,
but we’ll explain all that at the end, I
promise.
Way back in 2015, when the world made sense,
NASA’s New Horizon mission flew by the dwarf
planet, Pluto waay out near the Kuiper Belt
-- an asteroid field that encircles our solar
system.
At the time scientists felt they had this
planet figured out.
Then these images and the accompanying data
from Pluto completely blew their collective
braincases.
Since 2006 when the International Astronomical
Union updated their classification of the
word “planet” there’s been a huge debate
in the public, and in the scientific community,
about the fate of dwarf planets.
The IAU says a planet has to be a sun-orbiting
body that is massive enough to be round, and
will have cleared its orbit -- meaning nothing
gets in the way as it goes around the sun.
This definition keeps asteroids, comets, and
moons from being planets, but, it excludes
some smaller bodies (which is why Pluto is
now called a dwarf-planet).
So now, our solar system has eight planets,
and five dwarf planets: Ceres, Pluto, Eris,
Makemake, and Haumea!
That’s right, the current definition upgraded
four other objects and yet nobody talks about
it!
We have 13 planets in our solar system.
“Dwarf” planets aren’t technically planets,
though for some reason “giants,” and “ice
giants” are.
A new paper purports to change everything
when it comes to planetary classification.
The short paper, published in Lunar and Planetary
Science, wants to reclassify planets as a
round body that’s never undergone fusion,
and has less mass than a star.
That’s it.
This means, Pluto would be planet again…
which is great!
But it would also bring along friends; Ceres,
Eris, Makemake and Haumea would become planets
as well as 97 other objects.
Under this definition, our solar system would
have 110 planets…
There are several reasons scientists care
about this.
First, the current definition says all planets
have to orbit the sun.
Our sun.
This means, even though we’ve discovered
over 1,000 exoplanets, there are only 8 real
planets in the universe.
Planets orbiting other stars, aren’t orbiting
the sun and so aren’t technically planets.
Yes, it’s pedantic, this is science we’re
talking about.
Pedantry is part of the game.
On the other hand, both definitions count
being round as important, because it keeps
asteroids out of the planetary-club.
But, the front-row students are already pointing
out, the Moon is round.
And, yes.
Under this definition our Moon would be a
planet, as would all the round moons of Jupiter
and Saturn, and elsewhere!
Defining planets in the way the IAU does now
is quote “flawed,” according to scientist,
not just because it demoted Pluto, but it
also it does seems unfair to discount celestial
bodies that are as unique and interesting
as Saturn or Venus.
The researchers hope if we start recognizing
Makemake and Ceres and Io and Enceladus all
as planets, maybe we’ll get the budget to
go there!
This debate really pits branches of science
against each other.
Planetary geoscientists, want to physically
explore the planets, astronomers want to classify
and observe them.
One of the lead authors of this paper is Alan
Stern, an outspoken critic of the 2006 IAU
re-classification.
This debate was reignited because of the incredible
data scientists received from Pluto.
Plus, the things we’re learning about moons
like Europa, Enceladus, Titan, Io, and Ganymede.
Pluto, for example, is no longer considered
a boring icy rock zipping around out past
(but sometimes nearer, than) Neptune.
Instead, we know it has complex geological
processes which may hide a subsurface oceans,
glaciers of nitrogen, a thin atmosphere, and
its solar-planetary interaction is unique
and unlike the octet of pompous planets in
our solar system!
But does being more interesting than we thought
warrantPluto's un-demotion?
What do you think?
By now you may have noticed we’ve made some
changes to both the show and the channel.
And more changes will be happening over the
next couple of weeks.
We’re now officially Seeker.
Seeker is all about science, innovation, technology
and the universe around us.
We’ll be bringing you more in depth documentaries,
experiments, VR content, interviews and of
course, science updates from your favorite
hosts.
We have a lot of really awesome stuff in the
works, so please subscribe, check out Seeker.com
and our Facebook page and thanks for your
support.
Tell us your thoughts in the comments, and
if you want more incredible science, about
Pluto check out Ian O’Neill’s video on
it here, he’s an astrophysicist -- he knows
what he’s talking about.